[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video i'm going to be discussing
a bit of a controversial topic it's
something that pertains to both the
students and professors of hogwarts and
it's definitely not something positive i
am of course talking about corporal
punishment if you don't know already
corporal punishment is an old system of
punishment that was actually
surprisingly common in the school system
that is until it was banned in 1986 in
the uk at least other countries went on
to ban it at different points in time
and i think that it may actually still
be allowed in some places it's also
worth mentioning that corporal
punishment also exists outside of the
school system however the school system
will be the focal point of this video
corporal punishment involves inflicting
physical pain upon someone and in a
school setting it would be administered
when students failed to pay attention or
gave professors flack though not
restricted to these methods common
methods of inflicting pain would involve
spanking or paddling both of which are
completely unacceptable interestingly
enough however we do actually see
instances of corporal punishment in the
harry potter story most notably this
style of punishment is exercised by
severus snape who would routinely smack
students that were taking the mickey or
failing to listen to his instructions
but i wonder was snape actually allowed
to do this surely the magical school of
hogwarts doesn't condone this sort of
behavior right let's dive in a bit
further the truth is the regulations
involving corporal punishment at
hogwarts seemed to be at the discretion
of whoever was headmaster for example
there was evidence in the text to
support a dumbledore was against it
professor umbridge seized mariessa
pulled around to face her and began
shaking her very hard a split second
later dumbledore was on his feet his
wand raised kingsley started forwards
and umbridge leapt back from marietta
waving her hands in the air as though
they had been burned i could not allow
you to manhandle my students dolores
said dumbledore there is also evidence
in the copper to fire to support that
mcgonagall was against it as well
teach moody is that a student shrieked
professor mcgonagall the book spilling
out of her arms yep said moody no cried
professor mcgonagall running down the
stairs and pulling out her wand a moment
later with a loud snapping noise draco
malfoy had reappeared lying in a heap on
the floor with his sleek blonde hair all
over his now brilliantly pink face he
got to his feet wincing moody we never
use transfiguration as a punishment said
professor mcgonagall weekly surely
professor dumbledore told you that he
might have mentioned it yeah said moody
scratching his chin unconcernedly but i
thought a good sharp shock umbrage on
the other hand was all for it as clearly
shown in the i will not tell lies
segment from the order of the phoenix
she also planned to introduce a few
educational decrees that would allow
hitting students much to the delight of
filch i've been telling dumbledore for
years and years he's too soft with you
all said phil chuckling nastily you
filthy little beasts would never have
dropped stink pellets if you'd known i
had it in my power to whip you raw would
you now nobody would have thought of
throwing fanged frisbees down the
corridors if i could have strung you up
by the ankles in my office would they
but when educational decree number 29
comes in potter i'll be allowed to do
them things this quote also gives us an
important bit of information educational
decree 29
so what does educational decree 29
actually state apparently this decree
would have given argus filch proper
permission to physically punish students
for misbehaving fortunately this decree
never came to pass however there was
something almost as bad a form called
the approval for whipping form this form
would effectively give filch the same
power that the decree would and would
allow him to hit the students a dream
come true for someone like filch
approval for whipping approval for
whipping i can do it at last we've had
it coming to them for years he pulled
out a piece of parchment kissed it then
shuffled rapidly back out of the door
clutching it to his chest filch elbowed
his way closer to umbridge almost crying
with happiness i've got the form
headmistress he said hoarsely waving the
piece of parchment harry had just seen
him take from her desk i've got the form
and i've got the whips waiting oh let me
do it now
filch had been wanting to physically
hurt students for years but under
dumbledore's administration never got
the chance this is reflected in the
following excerpt a highly polished
collection of chains and manacles hung
on the wall behind filter's desk it was
common knowledge that he was always
begging dumbledore to let him suspend
students by their ankles from the
ceiling however when it came time for
filch to exercise his approval for
whipping with fred and george they
clearly weren't having any of it very
good argus you two are about to learn
what happens to wrongdoers in my school
you know what i don't think we are
george i think we've outgrown full-time
education yeah i've been feeling that
way myself i think they made the right
move at the right time however it wasn't
just umbridge that was a proponent of
punishing students physically when
hogwarts was taken over and snape
assumed the role of headmaster the
carros amicus and alecto effectively had
free reign over hogwarts students given
that they are well evil death eaters i'm
sure you can imagine that they would
have been just fine with physically
hurting students and perhaps one of the
worst displays of corporal punishment
i've heard of apparently their preferred
method of administering pain was the
cruciatus curse if you can believe it do
you know about the caros those two death
eaters who teach here they do more than
teach said neville they're in charge of
all discipline they like punishment the
carers like umbridge nah they make her
look tame the other teachers are all
supposed to refer us to the carrows if
we do anything wrong they don't though
if they can avoid it you can tell they
all hate them as much as we do amicus
the bloke he teaches what used to be
defense against the dark arts except now
it's just the dark arts we're supposed
to practice the cruciatus curse on
people who've earned attentions i would
say that administering the cruciatus
curse is probably the pinnacle of
corporal punishment so it's fortunate
that the carriers weren't in power for
long or hogwarts would have had some
seriously disturbed graduates moving
forward however one thing that is worth
mentioning is that it appears that in
the olden days that is the days before
harry began attending the school
corporal punishment was far less frowned
upon this is conveyed in the following
quote from vilch in the philosopher's
stone follow me said filch lighting a
lamp and leading them outside i bet
you'll think twice about breaking a
school rule again won't you eh he
continued luring at them oh yes hard
work and pain and the best teachers if
you ask me it's just a pity they let the
old punishments die out hang you by your
wrists from the ceiling for a few days
i've got the chains still in my office
keep them well oiled in case they're
ever needed right off we go i don't
think of running off now it'll be worse
for you if you do so it looks like
corporal punishment wasn't too far gone
by the time harry had started as filch
himself seems to have participated in it
my guess is that it was actually
dumbledore that finally put a stop to it
when he took over as headmaster
generally it's argued that dumbledore
took over properly sometime between 1956
and 1964. so it looks like when snape
hit ron he was certainly in the wrong
however snape is snape so i'm sure that
it wouldn't have surprised the other
professors very much what do you guys
think did you ever wonder if this sort
of behavior was actually allowed let me
know in the comment section below
until next time it is the unknown we
fear when we look upon death and
darkness nothing more
[Music]
[Music]
you